directamente de la huerta pero la gente
no quería comprarlas porque tienen
algunas manchas pero desde que las abres
la belleza está en el interior
exactamente la belleza está en el
interior
lanza El desafío a los alumnos de este
colegio de París demostrar que pueden
hacer una buena pizza con estas verduras
que no tienen buen aspecto mezclando
harinas que quedaron de un taller de
cocina pasado y con restos de queso
y los jóvenes de 13 años logran con
creces el objetivo la alimentación cero
desperdicio es uno de los principales
temas de la escuela comestible que
enseña de manera lúdica a niños y
adolescentes la importancia de comer
bien
en Francia un cuarto de personas pasa
hambre así que solo por cuestiones
humanas aprender a no tirar es
importante también por ecología
producimos demasiado contaminamos y son
energías y petróleo que liberamos y por
economía También es importante poder
cocinar gastando
desperdicios alimentarios hay en cada
hogar pero a mayor escala también en los
supermercados este pequeño ubicado en el
distrito 14 retira de las estanterías
varios kilos por semana
aunque han llegado a la fecha
recomendada para el consumo marcada en
el paquete la ley permite su ingesta
hasta tres meses después
una parte importante de esos alimentos
los recupera jafar que trabaja para
Fénix una empresa solidaria de utilidad
social
lo que recolecta luego lo distribuye a
alguna asociación local
como este supermercado solidario del
distrito 14
la asociación
la asociación es muy importante para
nuestra asociación porque nos trae
productos frescos que no podemos comprar
conos sin crisis económica tenemos un
cierto número de familias que ayudar y
estamos llenos Aunque tenemos cada vez
más demandas
haciendo estas donaciones el
supermercado desgrava impuestos y se
ahorra dinero al no ocuparse de desechar
lo que no pudo vender negocio redondo
según Fénix que ya ha metido en este
círculo virtuoso a 500 supermercados